i had an idea because i usually play 3-0
i'm gonna play three two
so these will be slightly longer games
um
there'll be less dirty flagging
opportunities i'll have to actually get
decent positions oh did someone actually
redeem halloween gambit
oh i see joe2596
so every game i'll i'm white i'll play
at four nights
at some point i'll get it
this is maybe a problem i can't i can't
start a game
no one plays three two oh someone plays
three two
extermo 44 okay um
let's play chess okay e4 today until i
got a halloween
and then eventually i'll switch to
london
really get it oh first game first game
of the stream halloween garlit
to start the month of october opponent
is already petrified
um or maybe just as confused why i gave
a free piece
bishop b4
oh this is funny we're transposing into
a reverse center fork trick
it takes queen d4 actually queen g4 is
um the engine's choice
i like queen d4 though it's easier to
understand
after the game i'll have to check queen
g4
so i've had this exact position with
the black pieces i'll explain afterwards
how the temp the tempe work out
so i can consider taking weight free
pawn
hi she's winning a pawn here hi how's it
going
let's take um okay let's calculate takes
i guess there's a tricky move castling
but then i can take bishop d3 castle i
have the bishop pair
of what else let's take
because of knight takes which is like
what black probably wants to do then
queen takes g7
and the rook is a bit iffy
queen e7 doesn't hurt me i've rook off
fate
i have bishop h6 i might just be
winning the exchange
i guess there's queen f8 or not
yeah neither five doesn't hurt me
because i take the rook with check
i think yeah i'm winning material
this is a very nice start gotta post
more tennis
oh oh i have some tennis clips to show
maybe after this game
but let's focus let's not let the guard
down
um when you're up the exchange you want
to
still stay focused use open files to
your advantage
i have basically two one half open file
one fully open file
there's this move
a rookie five looks nice actually so i'm
pressuring
several different uh pressure points
i have rookie one if 94 i can take it
because king takes bishop takes b7
will win the rook with discover check
also hitting the bishop here it's more
money what kind of serve is your
favorite
um
the first serve ideally but then
my second favorite is the second serve
i like a slice serve it was hard to
serve today though
because there was wind and everything
kind of kept moving in random directions
okay c6 uh black wants to play b5 so
maybe i shift the rook back
everything's uh pretty solid here
play g3 just for good measure oh a5 was
kind of hanging a5 is still hanging
so i can take it h4 i'll play king f2
the bishop does a very nice job
restricting the knight
opponent wants to penetrate via h2 if
king here there's bishop d5
oh that was kind of tricky
king
wait okay let's focus opponent's getting
counter play
i mean i'm up so much i can probably
just allow the rook to come in
but i'd like to be clean as clean as
possible
i think i'll play i'm going to put the
rook back on e2
and then this will be my ideal setup
try and cover everything appropriately
if rook h2 i have king
g1
the nice thing about three two is um i
don't have to worry about time
i can take time to just try and get a
good position
and then i mean maybe eventually if i
get below five seconds but
i can safely know that i won't get dirty
flagged
it's a question how i make a past pawn
crook i have to get at this
knight the knight really holds the whole
position together
bishop d5 hello again eric hello again
who is that i'm not looking but probably
a
multi-month sub uh
maybe this move
now g3 might fall actually i'm actually
considering just running the king up
like all these squares are
never mind um
okay there's knight e4 bishop e4 i'll be
happy to trade
who was that oh that was anti-wiz
solving for 14 months
yeah again was a very appropriate word
thanks for subbing and rise vapor
solving with prime
okay so now i could take
and try and trade i could take takes
here and then put the rook here
and then chill oh wait that loses oh
that would be terrible knight c4 happens
real sub this time playing my first
rated tournament this weekend online oh
no way
well that's awesome good luck
play this move wait i have to focus
thanks for subbing though
i just have to stay focused on the chest
rather than the chat
um this is weirdly annoying
i mean everything's still solid
maybe c4 c4 is a nice idea
expecting rook g8 i might throw in this
move
i also have this idea
yeah i i played rookie 2 because the
bishop was controlling h1
i do want to shift over to the h file
it will defend the pawn first
it's hard for black to actually create
plans here
i could consider pushing my pawn could
maybe bring the king to b4
the goal here is to play a lot of quick
moves and to not
get too low on time
[Music]
capone is getting low on time too like
black is pretty much optimized
so it's hard to actually do anything
productive
okay and maybe c5 coming
that's not too harmful okay here i can
oh no i can't take
i keep forgetting about the forking
possibilities
yeah you have to be careful like if you
have two pieces on a dark square they
can get forked by
a knight now let's play c4
explosive
very soon i'll probably never mind
uh rookie five attacking a pawn
pressuring this too
oh we could trade
the thing is i don't want i don't want
to trade pawns
like when you're out material you want
to trade pieces and not pawns
i might just try and keep pushing play
this move
attacking this pawn
opponent my flag opponent was very close
to flagging there
now threatening this because the
knight's over worked
this works
[Music]
keep the bishop along this diagonal
threatening rookie six
i guess i had rookie six immediately
okay oh tricky tricky but here i'm up a
piece
check check
wait how do i win this okay i just have
to march the pawns up
maybe win a pawn
defend upon push upon
defend upon
okay and then create the meaning that
yeah there's no stalemate hope for black
king g6 coming threatening mates two
different mates in one
if that could just remove the rook in
the pawn it would be stalemate
but not possible
okay that was actually a hard fought
game halloween for the win
yeah that was the halloween was
requested like right before this game
nice to start off the stream start off
the month with uh
with a halloween so yeah most people
i i've seen people give back the piece
but usually if black gives back the
piece
um most people will play this this and
then
bishop b4 this is what i occasionally do
um after takes takes black is probably
like slightly slightly better
but it's playable um
so this position it was kind of funny
because
um if you keep this position in mind and
take a look at the position
after bishop c4 which is
i think considered dubious because of
knight takes e4
it's the center fork trick and then
takes
and then this and then this it's the
same thing but flipped
and white lost the tempo by playing this
and this so the tempos or the tempi are
exactly the same um
yeah i can switch here so same exact
position
so i've studied this before from the
black side after it takes takes i know
queen g5 is preferable
but it's slightly more confusing because
c6 is not defended
i guess idea ah the idea is after takes
we can take on b5
and knight d4 and we move back
interesting oh if castling there's
bishop h3
so more traps i had a game once
when i was nine years old actually i
showed it in a st louis chess club
lecture it's like a kid's class lecture
i was nine i was playing a much older
opponent
wasn't like over the board rapid
tournament i played queen d5
my opponent took with bishop played
knight g4
wow it's john bartholomew with a raid
thanks john
i'm just showing a game from when i was
nine years old
um i was black after knight knight to g4
i played bishop ace
bishop a6 preventing light from castling
uh why play knight e3 i play queen e5
i play oh white played f3 and then i
played bishop d6 very innocent
developing move white took
and now i'll let the chat find the
winning move here for black black to
move
and win in beautiful fashion
and thankfully i managed to find this
despite my young age
also shout out to john john's been
streaming a lot more recently
uh john where i follow you hope you had
a good stream
i caught some of john's stream yesterday
oh wait i raided jon yesterday oh so
maybe jon's just returning the raid
i was watching john yesterday and then
i was praying for him because he had a
bad position
and my prayers worked he managed to like
win a losing position
oh chad is oh chad is actually
very clever i think most people in chat
see it
also if this goes on youtube people can
let me know in the youtube comments if
you found the move
so some people in chat suggesting queen
takes h2
which is probably the second best move
you can take the pawn
say oh no my queen and then checkmate
but queen takes h2 is not so forcing
because it's not check
so the better move is queen g3
and then takes takes and
this is one of the nicest miniatures
i remember from my childhood it's nice
to sack a queen
and checkmate within 13 moves
so anyway i was just showing this
because this comes from a center fork
trick
and the game i just played was a
halloween gambit
that transposed into a reverse center
portrait
so we basically got the same position um
if knight g5 it would have been the
exact same opponent played this
which i think just allowed me to win
material
or not oh oh i think i was aware of this
after it takes black and castle
and this defends the knight with tactics
maybe there's some compensation here
so i should have i have f3
bishop a3 is also pretty standard
anyway um i'm gonna probably put this
whole thing on youtube
uh with uh the halloween game the john
bartholomew raid
and uh this this flashback from when i
was nine years old
uh so people on youtube hope you enjoyed
that nice start to
uh the month of october and feel free to
subscribe and follow on twitch
and check out john bartholomew on twitch
too it's been streaming a lot more
recently and have a good month